there you go right on the lens oh we
have a problem we don't have a mic
Mountain I will try to get a mic on this
camera ASAP I hate blood if Jake ever
asked me to do anything with blood again
I don't know if I can say yes now I'm
taking the [ __ ] today oh yeah I have not
taken the [ __ ] today none of us have is
there anyone else thinking about it
here with Brett and Nikko and Derrick hi
all right we need everybody for this
because what we're gonna do is we're
gonna wrap Brett in duct tape why we
need to put a fake head with an
explosive on a body tomorrow on set so
that the head explodes well you can't
really do that on a real actor so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna wrap them
in duct tape and then cut them out of
the duct tape which will hopefully leave
a perfectly formed human model will it
work what's that what's that state if we
don't succeed there's dignity because
he'll be stripped nude after Anabaptist
the duct tape has been peeled off
kind of out of the close like Danny and
the clothes are going to hold most of
the structure Oh easy few nice fish oh
yeah
thank you Jake we can thank you you can
clear frame now all right sir here we
are at Morman rock in Southern
California we got Gavin from the slow mo
guys in Achievement Hunter hello hello
there I'm Gavin done
we're the slow mo guys god dammit god
dammit
flew out last night I did we had a super
early call time 6:00 a.m. this morning
up first obstacle 6 a.m. and our first
obstacle is phantom has a peel melt and
we only have yet EF lenses canon lenses
yep so we looked into finding adapter
that it doesn't look like those exist
this place is open and they do have a pl
mines then we should be fine I'm going
to assume that there's a rental
requirement for insurance on this I'm
going to assume that there's an option
where they put an insane amount of hold
on your credit card so
good morning
we have a problem
just first thing we had to send Brett up
to get the lenses he doesn't have any
corridor information and his phone was
dead I gave him my phone because he
didn't have a charger on him then I gave
him Spencer's number because I knew
Spencer would be sitting next to me in
the car
I gave him my credit card and my ID so
that he could go to the rental house so
now he's getting a rental with my credit
card and my ID at a rental house with my
phone and he's calling Spencer to talk
to me so Carmichael's got a little much
we are patient outside of our location
which is over there do this location is
perfect and the dog runs at you and then
it cut our cuts to a shot of you of
basically rock you coming around the
corner with the bottle in his mouth
running and you chasing after and you
get the yeah yeah so we can shoot a
bounce fast you described
yeah so we only it will be done in ten
minutes
how's the hike Spencer cuz I I don't
know if you've ever met Gavin but he's a
very busy guy we only have access to him
for a day you get a lot done in the day
can snapshot go Helen right Ren we have
a full video plan normally it something
like this it would take two days to
shoot but we're gonna try to do in one
day because we only have one day would
you do to prepare yourself to be a volte
survivor prepare for this role well I
came out here a day early and I burn the
whole place down I let see me I had a
flamethrower
oh oh that's thanks man I was really
considered a really got me in character
it's like a destroyer of things and also
ideal for the location it's really
really serendipitous that this fire came
through here I mean not for the people
who were victims of the fire but the
fact that it left this in its wake
perfect for this shoot well it's pretty
much perfect you'll be about right here
you got your gun basically it's along
like a hunter's gun you're not starving
yet but if you don't find food in the
next 24 hours let's see you come up the
hill with
stop right here and when you get to
right here
sorry for any of the bad audio that may
happen from this point on our mic mount
for the red rope so I had to put the BTS
mic onto the red mic mouth broke like
what do you say
Kilis tonight okay as you can see we got
to collect that tune down there that's
valuable oh yeah
fix uh fix my screw gun Nadia's got a
more settlements make more sell you know
actually building those settlements was
a lot of filming it was the most fun
dealing that and getting people to
settle in there and [ __ ] that turns into
what the game is you're just building
giant masses and campus it's like they
were there never ever actually satisfied
like everyone all the time it was always
like oh we need more resources on I have
everything connected yeah everyone has
what they need ya know but I don't get
about this [ __ ] does I say the
post-apocalyptic world who dressed like
this that was reason got Bermuda shorts
in like penny loafers man that could
happen I could have
you
I even know how to describe whatever
everything is gone wrong with these
blood bags I hate blood disgusting
yes
we came down this wash to get here for
some reason when Brad went to go get
lunch he exited the wrong way drove up
the wash rather than up the road you'll
see if we can get him out yeah it's the
one thing if your wheels start spinning
there it is 7:30 p.m.
how long have you been up I've been up
since like 4:30 a.m.
alright ready 3 2 1
not even moving he's got a phone and
Brett what did the tow people the guy
with the monster truck car Mike I said
there's no trucks available 175 per hour
just are you slowly brightening it I
just looked at the light why did I do
that I guess it gets brighter when you
actually look at it look what I need put
these numbers oh yeah this is yeah this
is off-road yeah okay uh well well we'll
keep calling around then so you see like
there's that big triangle there pointed
to the last bars is good red one right
yeah on the left the tip Saturn's the
top right damn you Caroline you brought
this upon us good although the reason
why I'm calling you is a bit of an
inconvenience I
all righty yeah no worries I figured it
was worth a shot so yeah I I mean I
don't I don't know what to do right now
can't find somebody then we [ __ ] we go
to plan B which is come back tomorrow
you have to call around tomorrow
and find a way that someone can pick you
up and bring you up here and pull the
car out it's going to be super expensive
that's yeah or Derrick could drive you
up and then you can call a tow truck and
have a meeting here actually that would
be better
alrighty I think let's go make some room
in the other cars I'm just waiting on
Derrick to confirm that but it looks
like he'll be able to help you basically
just wait on a tow truck I think you'd
be okay with a tow truck just they've
gonna have they're gonna need I mean if
the driver is okay with it the driver
should be the judge of their own I don't
say I'm hold
you